foreign
women's wear now has room for your tool
Adidas has launched its new Pride
collection featuring what appears to be
a biological male model in a bathing
suit men for women and I say appears
because he's got a package that would
throw out a FedEx driver's back
meanwhile a different dude modeling the
same swimsuit shows what it looks like
with your hair in a fabulous updo hey
girl
apparently the waxing kit is sold
separately uh
as former NCAA swimmer star Riley Gaines
tweeted Adidas could have at least
labeled it unisex and quote women's
swimsuits aren't accessorized with a
bulge
and she's right when I was a kid Adidas
is supposed to stand for all day I dream
about sex not all day I dream about
shrinkage
Michelle I'll come to you first as a
yeah
Michelle as a birthing person
were your fellow people who menstruate
asking for this were they asking for
this were any women asking for this
God no
um no you know Dylan Mulvaney has a
little song that he sings on Tick Tock
called normalize the Bulge normalize the
balls I'm not sure if this is what he
meant she meant but uh it's happening um
I'm getting to the point where there's
no brand I can buy anymore and feel good
about it like Nike's too entangle with
China I don't like the you know the
slave labor and the genocide and a
couple of those things about China my
kids have been wearing Adidas and now I
feel like every day I dream about you
know suicide
um this is brutal it's it's it's I wish
I had this person's hips I will say that
they're quite shapely
um but the rest of it I'm glad I don't
have
um this is this is again I think what
we're seeing is I I don't know what
calculus these companies are taking
because the Dylan Mulvaney Bud Light
thing really backfired I don't know if
they're saying hey we got to jump on
this we got to get we got to get talked
about I'm not sure if that's the
calculus now yeah we got to be
politically correct and talk about I'm
not sure but I have a feeling there may
be some backlash yeah I'm with you there
I feel like it's seeping into pop
culture are you concerned in that regard
as a TV writer that we're going to watch
Paul McCartney saying I saw them
standing there
um uh yeah I guess I'm so just concerned
when I saw the picture I really thought
that that I mean I don't know how else
to put this I just thought she had taken
a dump
[Laughter]
and I thought not get out of the pool
really get out of the pool uh I don't
suppose I can't put it any other way
I actually like the I mean as somebody
who I mean I don't know maybe you you
and I are the same but we don't work out
I like the old style men's bathing suits
that were like you know where they were
wearing the like on the beach and
they're wearing like a t-shirt and if
they could just have that and then just
a regular old trunks I'd be in yeah like
the singlet I'm into everybody looks
good in that even like fat guys who are
wrestling in the 1930s movies it's like
I I look better than that guy give me
the King Kong Bundy yeah exactly right
right
um but what's weird about it is that
like we're still I mean
we're still talking about like this tiny
tiny subset yes of people it's so
bizarre to me like that like I can't
imagine you make any money like the
number of people who are gonna run out
and buy even in a perfect world because
I feel like gotta be like what six
people yeah that's what I mean I feel
like it would turn off more people than
it would even Court given the population
size again from a distance that looks
like something else yeah
here's the thing I was going to ask you
like women have so many things they're
self-conscious about like is this now
going to be a thing now women are
worried that their penis doesn't look
big enough at the beach like
like seriously like in five years are
people going to be getting Brazilian
ball lifts you know
honestly
there have been bathing suit ads that
I've seen that I have felt represented
me less than this one
I don't have the penis but the cleavage
is about the same
and we also maybe like do we know is
this a trans person or is this just like
a dude that likes wearing women's
clothes my friend Keith wears my clothes
all the time for the same size but he's
just a he him who likes he hims okay we
don't know but I think we should we
don't have an answer for a lot for in
the future for women to be saying does
this penis make me look fat
that's
it's coming it's gets I have nothing to
add it's kind we all know it we all know
it's coming um I will ask you this
though we don't know if the person yeah
we don't know we know our appearances
that he is this is what I wanted to ask
you for real there's a serious question
though
um I think you know because these these
low corporate marketing firms they know
that the customers don't want this I
think on some level they're trying to
change their sensibilities to get a
higher Dei score the social credit score
the corporations get do you think about
some level that goes on it's a super
fascinating question and what I would
point out is there are lots of men
pretending to be women who are making
lots of money yes off of pretending to
be women which I think is an insult to
women totally but think about this there
isn't a single famous woman who is
pretending to be a man right so we talk
all this time about the trans Universe I
mean you can maybe point to the Ellen
Page Elliott page situation but she was
famous as an actor and now her career is
basically over now that she's a a man
and so men and I think it's we don't
hear this discuss much but I think men
just feel bad because if you're a woman
pretending to be a man you probably are
not that big strong or fast you
certainly aren't going to win a
championship in sports and men just kind
of ignore it you're you can do whatever
you want women it seems to me my wife is
big on this this is the ultimate
misogyny yeah because you're a man and
you're a racing women yeah and you're
winning championships and now you're
wearing women's bathing suits and you're
supposed to be able to embrace it I
don't understand why women aren't just
like this is ridiculous men no pun
intended there men have certainly made
that choice and and as a result this
really only Moves In One Direction yeah
right no I agree the only upside to this
whole thing for real is they have
single-handedly destroyed the gender pay
Gap myth Dylan Mulvaney was a starving
actor as a man he's been a woman for a
year he's worth 10 million bucks woman
of the year he's woman of the year
or it's over hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else